BRET?
>> Bret: CHAD PERGRAM LIVE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THANKS.
LET'S BRING IN OHIO REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN WHOSE
APPOINTMENT TO THE COMMITTEE WAS
REJECTED BY HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI.
SPEAKER JORDAN, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
>> GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Bret: DID YOU CATCH.
>> I GOT TO SEE PART OF IT.
I WAS ON ANOTHER SELECT
COMMITTEE ONE PELOSI HAS ALLOWED
ME TO BE ON THE CORONAVIRUS
SELECT COMMITTEE.
I GOT TO WATCH BITS AND PIECES
BUT I WAS ACTUALLY IN A
COMMITTEE HEARING ASKING
QUESTIONS AND MAKING STATEMENTS.
>> Bret: YOU SAW THE REVIEW
THERE BY CHAD.
OBVIOUSLY EMOTIONAL POWERFUL
TESTIMONY.
YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT.
>> NO.
IT WAS A TERRIBLE DAY.
THE PEOPLE WHO DID WRONG NEED TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
BRET, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THE REAL QUESTION IS AND I HAVE
SAID THIS MANY TIMES IS WHY
WEREN'T THOSE GUYS WHO TESTIFIED
TODAY AND ALL THE OTHER CAPITOL
HILL POLICE WHO PROTECT US AND
PROTECT CAPITOL HILL WHY WEREN'T
THEY GIVEN MORE HELP?
WHY WASN'T MORE HELP THERE THAT
DAY IN THE ONLY PERSON WHO CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION IS THE
SPEAKER OF THE UNITED STATES
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
AND I THINK SHE THOUGHT WE WERE
GOING TO KEEP RAISING THAT
QUESTION AND THAT'S WHY SHE
DIDN'T PUT ME ON BECAUSE,
REMEMBER, BRET, THERE WAS A
STORY IN POLITICO LAPSE
WEDNESDAY MORNING WHICH MEANS
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE TALKED TO
THE PRESS THE DAY BEFORE THAT
SAID THAT THE HEADLINE SAID
DEMOCRATS ACCEPT LEADER
McCARTHY'S SELECTION AND THEN
SOMETHING CHANGED.
I THINK IT'S THE FACT THAT I
RAISED THAT ISSUE LAST TUESDAY.
THAT FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IS THE
ONE THAT NEEDS TO BE ANSWERED
THE FACT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO RAISE THAT I THINK
IS THE REASON WE ARE NOT ON THE
COMMITTEE.
>> Bret: HOW WOULD YOU HAVE
ASKED THAT TODAY?
>> THE FOCUS TODAY IS WHY WE
DIDN'T HAVE MORE PEOPLE THERE
ONE OF THE OFFICERS I THINK I
DID SEE PART OF THIS WHERE HE
SAID WE WEREN'T PREPARED FOR
WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHY WEREN'T YOU?
WHY WASN'T THE INFORMATION GIVEN
TO YOU?
THERE HAVE BEEN NEWS REPORTS
THAT SAID SPEAKER PELOSI VETOED,
VETOED BRINGING THE NATIONAL
GUARD HERE.
AND THEN THE DAY OF THE ATTACK
THERE HAS BEEN NEWS REPORTS THAT
SAID SHE HESITATED ON CALLING UP
THE NATIONAL GUARD.
WHY?
MY HUNCH IS, BRET, MY HUNCH IS
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED ALL LAST
SUMMER?
LAST SUMMER WE SAW SPEAKER
PELOSI AND THE DEMOCRATS SAY
THAT WE SHOULD DEFUND THE
POLICE.
WE SAW SPEAKER PELOSI AND THE
DEMOCRATS SAY THAT RIOTERS AND
LOOTERS TO DESTROYED SMALL
BUSINESS AND HURT CIVILIANS THEY
RAISED MONEY TO BAIL THEM OUT OF
JAIL.
WHEN THAT'S THE BACKGROUND CAN'T
SAY WE ARE FOR DEFUNDING THE
POLICE BUT WANT MORE POLICE TO
PROTECT US ON JANUARY 6TH.
>> Bret: HERE IS CONGRESSMAN
JEFFRIES ADDRESSING WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THERE AND SPEAKER
PELOSI.
>> THE FACT THAT KEVIN
McCARTHY CONTINUES TO BLAME
SPEAKER PELOSI IS JUST SUCH A
SICK AND CYNICAL ACT OF
DIVERSION AND DESCRATION.
THOSE PROTESTERS WERE THERE IN
PART TO ASSASSINATE NANCY
PELOSI.
WHAT DOES KEVIN McCARTHY NOT
GET ABOUT THAT?
>> Bret: YOUR RESPONSE?
>> NO ONE IS BLAMING ANYONE FOR
WHAT HAPPENED THAT DAY EXCEPT
THE PEOPLE WHO DID WRONG.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE TO BLAME.
AND, GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE BEING PROSECUTED JUST
LIKE OUR SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK.
WE'RE JUST ASKING A FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION.
A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
IF THERE ARE NEWS REPORTS THAT
SAID THAT SPEAKER PELOSI VETOED
HAVING THE NATIONAL GUARD THERE,
THAT THE SERGEANT OF ARMS SAID
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE TOLD HIM
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OPTICS, THAT'S A REAL QUESTION.
THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
WHY WASN'T THERE A PROPER
SECURITY POSTURE ON JANUARY 6TH
AND WHAT HAVE WE DONE TO CORRECT
THAT AND SO IT MAKES SURE IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE?
I THINK IT WAS A FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION.
IT'S NOT ABOUT BLAME.
THE BLAME RESIDES WITH THE
PEOPLE WHO DID WRONG.
THEY SHOULD BE PROSECUTED AND
THEY ARE BEING.
>> Bret: WELL, THERE WAS A
LITTLE BIT OF TALK ABOUT BLAME
TODAY.
OFFICER GONNEL TALKING ABOUT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT STIRRING UP
THAT CROWD.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> ALL OF THEM WERE TELL US
TRUMP SENT US.
NOBODY ELSE, THERE WAS NOBODY
ELSE THAT WAS NOT ANTIFA.
IT WAS NOT BLACK LIVES MATTER,
IT WAS NOT THE FBI, IT WAS HIS
SUPPORTER THAT HE SENT THEM OVER
TO THE CAPITOL THAT DAY.
AND HE COULD HAVE HAD DONE A LOT
OF THINGS.
ONE OF THEM WAS TO TELL THEM TO
STOP.
>> Bret: ALL HIS OFFICERS SAID
THERE IS NOT POLITICS INVOLVED
IN THIS.
THEY ARE TESTIFYING OF WHAT THEY
BELIEVED HAPPENED THAT DAY AND
THEIR REACTION TO IT.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT
HE JUST SAID THERE?
>> WELL, I BELIEVE CAPITOL HILL
POLICE.
THE GREAT WORK THEY DO.
THERE IS NOT POLITICS THERE.
THERE IS CERTAINLY POLITICS WITH
THIS COMMITTEE.
WE KNOW THIS COMMITTEE IS OUT TO
GET THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WHO SAID
THAT DAY PEACEFULLY AND
PATRIOTICALLY MAKE YOUR VOICES
HEARD.
WE SAW THE PRESIDENT'S ENTIRE
SPEECH.
THAT'S BEEN SEEN AND VIEWED AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TIMES.
WE HAVE HAD ALL KINDS OF
COMMENTATORS.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ HAS TALKED ABOUT
IT THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T INCITE
ANYTHING.
THE PEOPLE WHO DID WRONG, THEY
NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY ARE BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AS WE SPEAK.
>> Bret: THIS COMMITTEE IS
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO GO DOWN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ROADS ABOUT
WHO KNEW WHAT WHEN, WHO WAS
TALKING TO COORDINATORS OF THE
PROTESTS.
DID YOU TALK TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT THAT DAY?
>> I HAVE TALKED TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT UMPTEEN TIMES,
THOUSANDS.
>> Bret: ON JANUARY 6TH?
>> I TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT.
I NEVER TALK ABOUT WHAT WE TALK
ABOUT.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
JUST LIKE I DON'T TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS IN REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSES.
I TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT
NUMEROUS TIMES.
I CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: NO, NO.
I MEAN ON JANUARY 6TH,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> YES.
I TALK TO THE PRESIDENT.
I HAVE TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT -- I CAN'T REMEMBER
ALL THE DAYS I HAVE TALKED TO
HIM BUT I HAVE CERTAINLY TALKED
TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: AND ON THAT DAY, CAN
YOU SHARE ANY OF THE INSIGHT OF
WHAT HE WAS THINKING THAT DAY?
>> BRET, THE PEOPLE WE NEED TO
COME TESTIFY ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
CAN TESTIFY TO THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS.
WHY DIDN'T THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL, THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE,
HAVE AN APPROPRIATE SECURITY
POSTURE ON THAT DAY AND WHAT
HAVE WE DONE -- THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE WE NEED TO HEAR FROM.
THAT'S THE INFORMATION AND
TESTIMONY WE NEED TO GET.
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD FOCUS ON.
BUT I DON'T THINK -- BENNIE
THOMPSON, THE CHAIRMAN OF THIS
COMMITTEE SAID EVERYTHING IS ON
THE TABLE UNTIL WE RAISE THIS
ISSUE ABOUT THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE
IS THE ONE WHO KNOWS WHAT THE
SECURITY POSTURE AND WHY IT WAS
THE WAY IT WAS.
ONCE WE RAISE THAT QUESTION,
WELL, EVERYTHING IS ON THE TABLE
EXCEPT THAT QUESTION.
AGAIN, THAT'S WHY I THINK WE
WERE KICKED OFF THE COMMITTEE
WHICH I THINK UNDERSCORES HOW
POLITICAL THIS THING ACTUALLY IS
AND I WOULD ARGUE THIS:  THE
MAIN REASON DEMOCRATS WANT TO
KEEP TALKING ABOUT JANUARY 6TH,
BECAUSE WHAT THE HECK ELSE ARE
THEY GOING TO TALK ABOUT, BRET?
ARE THEY GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
12 MURDERS IN CHICAGO LAST WEEK?
PRICE OF SERVICES AND GOOD UP
FOR EVERYTHING?
ARE THEY GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
FACT OURWARD, WE HAD A RECORD
NUMBER OF ILLEGAL CROSSINGS IN
MARCH UNTIL APRIL AND THEN WE
HAD A RECORD NUMBER APRIL UNTIL
MAY.
RECORD NUMBER IN MAY UNTIL JUNE.
THAT IS A BAD -- THEY CAN'T TALK
ANY OF THAT STUFF.
FOCUS ON WHAT THEY ALWAYS DO
ATTACK THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: ALWAYS THINGS WE ARE
COVERING EXTENSIVELY HERE.
FINALLY YOU HEARD THESE
OFFICERS, A NUMBER OF THEM SAY
THEY WERE DISMAYED BY LAWMAKERS
WHO SEEM TO, IN THEIR WORDS,
SEEM TO BE DOWN PLAYING
JANUARY 6TH OR THE MAGNITUDE OF
IT.
>> I NEVER.
>> Bret: I'M NOT ACCUSING YOU,
CONGRESSMAN.
IS THERE A MESSAGE FOR LAWMAKERS
WHO MAY HAVE DONE THAT.
>> THE MESSAGE IS I HAVE NEVER
DOWN PLAYED JANUARY 6TH.
WHAT I HAVE DONE AND WHAT WE
HAVE DONE AND REPUBLICANS HAVE
DONE.
WE HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT.
WE SAID WHAT HAPPENED LAST
SUMMER IN SO MANY OF OUR URBAN
AREAS TO POLICE OFFICERS AND
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND FELLOW
CITIZEN WAS AS WRONG AS WRONG
COULD BE.
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH WAS
AS WRONG AS WRONG COULD BE.
WE HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T ARE THE
DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S WHY THEY CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THIS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY
DEFUNDED THE POLICE AND ALL THE
THINGS WHEN THEY SAID THEY
RAISED MONEY TO BAIL OUT RIOTERS
AND LOOTERS FROM JAIL.
THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT THOSE
THINGS.
THEY ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON THI